[Música]
el ex ministro del interior de perú
mariano gonzález apuntó al presidente
pedro castillo de corrupción y de
obstruir la justicia el funcionario fue
citado ante la fiscalía para ampliar sus
declaraciones que dio a conocer luego de
que el mandatario peruano lo despidió
iván duque pronunció su último discurso
antes del congreso como presidente de
colombia el mandatario habló en la
posición de los nuevos legisladores pero
la oposición que ahora será gobierno lo
abucheó en varias ocasiones
eeuu tilda de corruptos a 60
funcionarios y antiguos empleados del
salvador honduras guatemala y nicaragua
nos agregó a la lista engel como que les
prohíbe el ingreso a suelo
estadounidense tenemos reportes de
nuestro corresponsal en centroamérica
bienvenidos a las noticias qué france24
le dedica a américa mi nombre es maría
clara calle y es un placer acompañarlos
iniciamos hablando de perú porque el ex
ministro del interior mariano gonzález
acusó al presidente pedro castillo de
corrupción y de obstruir la justicia
luego de que el mandatario lo
destituyera tan sólo dos semanas después
de haberlo nombrado gonzalo gonzález
habló ante la fiscalía y los abogados de
castillo replicaron que están pensando
en denunciarlo por difamación no es la
única dificultad que enfrenta el
presidente pues los transportistas están
haciendo un paro a lo largo del país
manuel a cano con los detalles
para que en un nuevo capítulo de la
eterna crisis política de perú poco
tiempo después de ser destituido como
ministro del interior por pedro castillo
mariano gonzález lanzó una serie de
acusaciones contra el mandatario tengo
ninguna duda del compromiso que el señor
tiene con la corrupción y no tengo
ninguna duda que esta salida abrupta
tiene que ver con obstruir la
administración de justicia el ex
ministro también aseguró que fue
retirado el cargo que ocupó sólo durante
dos semanas por haber creado un grupo
especial de la policía nacional que se
encargaría de investigar a varios altos
funcionarios del gobierno luego de
conocer dicho testimonio la fiscalidad
del país llamó a testificar a gonzález
la fiscal de la nación cita al ex
ministro del interior mariano gonzález
para tomar su declaración por los hechos
relatados que configurarían presuntos
actos delictivos una citación que
profundiza la inestabilidad del gobierno
del castillo que el martes nombró a
willy huerta como el séptimo funcionario
en cabeza de dicho ministerio pero el
inestable panorama político del país
latinoamericano no radica únicamente en
los constantes cambios igualmente
asumidas de que castillo cumpla un año
en su cargo se enfrenta a un paro de
transportistas que bloquea las salidas y
entradas de varias ciudades del país un
descontento que se espera que llegue a
lima la próxima semana y que amenaza con
obstaculizar la continuidad de castillo
en su cargo la aprobación del mandatario
se encuentra en un 25 por ciento y la
huelga en perú no es la única
manifestación que hay en la región
hagamos un repaso de las protestas en
américa latina' la inflación y el
aumento de la pobreza es lo que rechazan
los manifestantes en argentina en una
nueva protesta vivida en una renta
básica universal al gobierno del
presidente alberto fernández el malestar
social ha crecido mientras las
autoridades buscan mecanismos para pagar
la deuda de 44 mil millones de dólares
al fondo monetario internacional
en puerto rico las protestas son para
exigirle al ejecutivo que cancele el
contrato con uma energía pues en el año
en el que esta empresa privada ha
distribuido la electricidad el reemplazo
de la estatal autoridad de energía
eléctrica los precios de las facturas de
la luz han aumentado siete veces a pesar
de los múltiples apagones que hace
en el salvador decenas de familias
salieron a las calles contra la
prolongación del estado de excepción
luego de que el congreso de mayoría
oficialista aprobara la cuarta
ampliación de la propuesta del
presidente en el gym bukele los
manifestantes alegan que durante la
medida de excepción comenzó a finales de
marzo las autoridades han detenido de
manera arbitraria a cientos de personas
y en colombia el presidente saliente
iván duque hizo un balance de sus cuatro
años de gobierno en un discurso oficial
que dio para la instalación del nuevo
congreso pero el mandatario fue
abucheado en varios momentos por la
oposición que ahora entrará a ser parte
del nuevo gobierno de la izquierdista
gustavo petro precisamente el nuevo
congreso colombiano tiene varias
novedades para comenzar una inédita
bancada de izquierda y una amplia
coalición de gobierno dos tercios de los
integrantes son caras nuevas en las dos
cámaras y será la primera vez que tenga
el número más alto de mujeres
legisladoras y de integrantes de la
comunidad lgbt y q más también en un
hecho inédito hasta ahora habrá 16
representantes a la cámara en nombre de
los lugares más golpeados por el
conflicto armado escuchemos lo que dijo
duke
propusimos transformar positivamente a
colombia y prepararla para los retos del
futuro sobre las bases de la legalidad
el emprendimiento y la equidad hemos
cumplido
eeuu incluyó en su lista engel a 60
funcionarios y ex empleados públicos del
salvador honduras guatemala y nicaragua
los acusan de ser corruptos y de ser
antidemocráticos la inclusión en la
lista implica que ninguna de las
personas podrán entrar a territorio
estadounidense ni tener visados para
viajar a ese país desde ciudad de
guatemala nuestro corresponsal andrés
suárez nos explicó cuáles son los
nombres más destacados y como la lista
de afecta a los actuales gobiernos
centroamericanos
bueno empecemos por ejemplo con el
salvador hay uno de los nombres uno de
los nombres más destacados es el de
cristian guevara él es diputado de la
asamblea legislativa también es el jefe
del partido de nadie busque el e ideas
nuevas nuevas ideas que está acusado de
haber sido la persona que promulgó
promovió la ley en contra de los
periodistas en el estado de excepción
que puedan llegar a ser encarcelados
hasta por 15 años y difunden mensajes
de las pandillas en guatemala por
ejemplo se encuentra josé rafael
curruchiche actual jefe de la fiscalía
especial contra la impunidad acusado de
obstrucción de todo tipo de
investigaciones en honduras varios de
los implicados por haber malversado
500.000 dólares de un programa
presidencial destinado a la pobreza más
de 500 mil dólares y en nicaragua 23
jueces y fiscales que fueron aquellos
que les imputaron cargos falsos y
encarcelaron a
grandes dirigentes de la oposición en el
marco de las elecciones que llevaron a
daniel ortega a la presidencia de
nicaragua
la expresidenta de chile michelle
bachelet respaldo abiertamente el
apruebo una de las dos opciones que
tendrán los chilenos en el plebiscito
que votarán el 4 de septiembre desde
perú y horas antes de llegar a su país
natal actual alta comisionada de la onu
para los derechos humanos se mostró a
favor de la nueva constitución que
redactaron los constituyentes en
reemplazo de la que rige desde la
dictadura de augusto pinochet esto fue
lo que dijo
y yo tengo muy clara de lo que debiera
ser la decisión del 4 de septiembre yo
lo he dicho antes yo estoy por el pro de
la reforma y la constitución segundo no
tengo ninguna intención de volver a
postularse presidente la república eso
se lo puedo decir de inmediato en eeuu
unos 100 millones de ciudadanos estarán
bajo advertencias climáticas esta semana
ante el panorama del presidente joe
biden anunció acciones ejecutivas contra
la crisis climática como 2.300 millones
de dólares para centros de enfriamiento
la promoción de nuevos proyectos eólicos
marinos en el golfo de méjico y ayudas a
las familias pobres para apagar la
calefacción y la refrigeración sin
embargo las medidas están lejos de lo
que piden los legisladores demócratas y
los activistas ambientales que quieren
que declaren formalmente una emergencia
climática
esto dijo baile
el cambio climático es literalmente una
amenaza existencial para nuestra nación
y para el mundo así que mi mensaje de
hoy es este dado que el congreso no está
actuando como debería y estos muchachos
aquí lo están haciendo pero no estamos
obteniendo muchos votos republicanos
esto es una emergencia una emergencia y
lo haré lo miraré de esa manera lo dije
la semana pasada y lo diré nuevamente
alto y claro como presidente usaré mis
poderes ejecutivos para combatir la
crisis climática en ausencia de una
acción del congreso
la primera dama ucraniana olena selenski
habló en el capitolio de eeuu y le pidió
a los legisladores que envíen más ayuda
militar a ucrania para contrarrestar lo
que llamó los juegos del hambre de rusia
en su discurso de 15 minutos se les
mostró vídeos de niños que según ella
habían resultado heridos o muertos por
la ofensiva rusa su intervención ocurrió
el mismo día en el que la casa blanca
anuncio del envío de otros cuatro
misiles de alta precisión llamados y
mars para completar un total de 16
ya comemos con
llegamos así al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24
[Música]